crime pays at least it does if you
happen to be the Clown Prince a recent
breakdown by variety revealed with the
stars of the year's biggest movies were
paid for their roles while Joaquin
Phoenix's salary for Joker wasn't quite
in line with your average lead in the
comic book film it was nothing to laugh
at either existing apart from the
established continuity of the DC movie
universe
Joker shocked the world by virtue of
generating major awards buzz making
roughly all of the money and being an
excellent complex film which is open to
wildly varying interpretations by design
as comic book movies go the flick was
made on a modest budget it cost sixty
two point five million dollars to
produce and studio Warner Brothers but
with an understated advertising campaign
particularly as contrasted with your
average Marvel Studios blockbuster
our symbol as a result Joker became one
of the most ridiculously profitable
movies of all time
surpassing 1 billion dollars at the
worldwide box office and making Warner's
grass look like a bunch of geniuses for
green lighting the film one of the ways
in which the flicks budget was kept in
check though was by paying Phoenix a
comparative fraction of what he might
have made it beat opted for a more
typical entry into the comic-book movie
genre for his role as fails comedian
turned agent of malevolence in October
smash at film Phoenix earned four point
five million dollars certainly not a
pittance but not exactly Robert Downey
jr. money either
speaking of Iron Man there exists the
distinct possibility that both he and
Phoenix will be up for statues from
awards time it sure would be interesting
to see how Academy voters think Downey's
role in the biggest movie of all time
stacks up against Phoenix's performance
and writer director Todd Phillips humble
little comic book movie believe it or
not when it comes to 2019 franchise
films Phoenix's salary for Joker is not
only on the low end
according to Variety it's kind of near
the lowest only Jessica Chastain who
anchored September's hit chapter 2 as
the adult Beverly Marsh was paid less
she took home 2.5 million dollars for
appearing in the Stephen King sequel and
it's fair to say that this was to be
expected considering that movies huge
ensemble cast as for the high end
variety notes that Downey will rake in a
whopping twenty million dollars for the
forthcoming the voyage of dr. Dolittle
the same amount that he received upfront
for his role in Avengers endgame note
the qualifier upfront when the dust
settled on that film's record-shattering
box office run Downey's back end pay had
put his total and Game earnings at an
eye-watering 75 million dollars by way
of comparison
Downey's co-star Chris Evans only scored
a fifteen million dollar pay date for
his final appearance as Captain America
Dwayne Johnson is also in the twenty
million dollar club having earned that
amount for his appearance in the summers
fast and furious presents Hobson Shaw
his co-star Jason Statham was paid
thirteen million dollars while Idris
Elba who portrayed the flicks villain
Brixton to come eight million dollars
also noteworthy is the fact that in 2020
the female stars of the most highly
anticipated comic book and franchise
fare will be earning paychecks much more
in line with those of their male
counterparts than in years past
for example after clocking a mere three
hundred thousand dollars to star in 2017
s Wonder Woman gal gadot
earn ten million dollars to reprise her
role in the upcoming Wonder Woman 1984
an amount much closer to what is
typically paid out to male stars of solo
superhero films meanwhile Margot Robbie
is reportedly earning between nine and
ten million dollars for returning to the
role of Harley Quinn in February's birds
of prey and Emily Blunt will pull down
between 12 and 13 million dollars to
star in the sequel to the hit 2018 morph
like the quiet place those whopping
salaries are creeping ever closer to
those being paid out to establish a
listers like Tom Cruise and Will Smith
the former will take home between 12 and
14 million dollars for appearing in the
top gun sequel maverick while the latter
will notch a 17 million dollar paycheck
for starring in bad boys for life
compared to those staggering totals you
could make the argument that Phoenix was
egregiously underpaid for starring in
Joker but you have to keep in mind that
Warner Brothers viewed the film as a
total gamble before it set the world on
fire somehow we doubt Phoenix is upset
he stated on more than one occasion that
he didn't make Joker for the money
anyway
and it also seems pretty likely I'll
have the last laugh come award season
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one